when you have a movie like The Avengers
which is part of something else
something bigger does that make your job
easier because you have things you don't
have to answer that you can set up as
well as pay off yeah easier and harder I
mean there's restrictions and but yeah a
lot of the questions have already been
answered so it's you know going in that
you've got what you've got to work with
so it's it's a bit of a comfort actually
yes please jump in here only right hi
there I've got a question for my son
who's 10 years old for the Avengers and
he would like to know before you start
filming the movies what's the thing you
get most excited about all the Avengers
for the Avengers other guys okay I get
most excited by cooking and eating
dinner I'm excited about hanging now
these degenerates wait is it I'm sorry I
skipped my turn translator were burning
left coming back to the coming back to
the world and seeing where these these
crazy people that were playing are
headed and knowing that uh that Joss is
going to take us there into his own
twisted psyche
probably my first costume fitting me
surrounded by many full-length mirrors
I'll say a similar response to Jeremy
Marvel has a great job of bringing a lot
of the same people together not just in
front of the camera behind the camera so
coming back together as a group it kind
of feels like a family it's a lot of
familiar faces it's like you know like a
high school reunion or something yeah as
soon as you said cooking I was like she
doesn't get it she misheard let's call
it Skaar Jim uh
watching you eat so nobody else does
yeah um I guess I would say I get most
excited about reading Joss's script
because it's so it's it's like it's the
big payoff after a long way and also all
of the letters that proof cover letters
yeah the cover letters before the
scripts are just Goodison movie yeah
they're so delightful and
self-deprecating and kind of awesome
suicide yeah um so that's my favorite
part
I'm just excited to be you know ya know
to be a part of it you know and that the
that just brought me along with the
honest journey and to this fantastic
group of actors box office bonuses
actress I
there's that the jumper here in the red
time they have it wait are they coming
before the movie starts shooting now yes
and by the way you got box-office bonus
Y J's ladies got the Avengers Assemble
in London I would say if someone asks
what do you think of Avengers agent
fantastic but if I answer the question
that's Tony Stark Robert Downey jr. I
probably not bad could mean better but
good movie two questions one is Joss
Whedon Ultron was a great rhythm deep
was that any easy decision to make
to cast Ultron as the main villain or
was it a long thinking process no I said
we should have Ultron in the second
movie before I decided to make the first
movie he's big he's powerful he's angry
he's metal he's strong enough to take
these guys on
and there was he's been angry for so
long that I think he might be a little
unhinged and I heard that I can write
that our second question is you guys
inspire a lot of people in the world if
you go across the panel who when you
guys are growing up who inspired you who
your big idols I'm intrigued
should we start with Paul and work our
way back down again John Lennon um
inspired me in one way and my characters
all um I think Gary Oldman's one of my
sort of inspirations so I think Gary
Oldman
alright so there
I'm Patrick Swayze and dirty dancing
well I was gonna I was gonna go like a
different way and I was gonna say my old
man oh no I was I was gonna say that's
to me that's you know that's you know
who I am as a man that comes first I
suppose Peter O'Toole
it'd have to be Gandhi
Ben Kingsley and Ben Kingsley I've
noticed about pop and Michelle Pfeiffer
and Faye Dunaway oh yeah yeah those were
the girls I like your work and Angeles a
spur to you as well who inspires you
Chris Evans dad what a gal just didn't
know him I got sort of felt in his
presence you could all like in here the
next person is a lady in the fourth row
with her heart not please please
hi I'm about a question for the girls
and how harrigan does it feel to play
two female superheroes in such a
male-dominated universe and I suppose
you had a bit more prominence compared
to the first movie was that intentional
Joss I'm different what comparisons I
seem to be more provenance of the female
characters in this one compared to the
first one was that intentional and how
did like the theme like scholar and
Elizabeth feel about that how empowering
does it feel how empowering oh yeah I
mean I I was just you know I just go
through the script in like skip through
and see oh clock what are their shoes
and there she is again
um those are the only parts I read
mm-hmm but uh no I it's it's it what's
great about playing this character is
that she's based in you know something
deep and something that I could hold on
to she's grounded in something very real
which is you know this kind of I think
she has experienced a lot of trauma and
she is you know sort of um she's she's
never really been able to be to kind of
make active choices for herself and now
and now she finally is now she's she's
ready for it and unfortunately it's just
kind of bad timing but um you know these
these kinds of things are something that
we can hold on through onto so that when
we're you know fighting the good fight
and shooting five eighths of a page over
you know two weeks
it kind of keeps us it keeps us involved
and you know keeps our keeps our head
straight so that's you know I'm looking
at it just from an actor looking for
material that's something that I can
substantial not just a female actor
looking for substantial work but thanks
Joss anytime and Elizabeth and I I mean
I'm just still thrilled just to be part
of this whole group and world it's um
it's a franchise that I've been watching
since the first Ironman and I think
they've just made such he that was like
anything long and I mean they make such
great films that have such a balance of
depth and humor and action and and
that's given but they're all humans that
have weaknesses and strengths and
especially in this film I think there's
a there's a special highlight on
everyone's own personal worlds and lives
and what makes them human so I think
that's what makes us this film so great
and it's just it's just amazing be part
of this this cast it's mind-boggling
let's gently here in the front row
thinking I'm sorry it's been 15 minutes
since my last wardrobe change every bad
Jimmy Jimmy yes please hi guys great
movie a couple of questions for Joss um
what's next for you apart from a long
rest and you see yourself returning to
the Marvel Universe one day um I don't
think I'll ever get that far away from
it because I love it so much after my
long rest I plan a longer rest and
possibly an eternal rest
I have no immediate plans which is the
best thing I've ever said mm-hmm yes
because Jim pink shirt about six rows
back thank you hi I've got a question
for Scarlett obviously your character
could have easily just been kind of
written off as the sexy one of the team
how important is it that Lee how
important is it for you that she's
actually smart as well as hot and are
you livid that there's not a black widow
film yet how important is what that
she's really intelligent as well as
being sexy and are you angry that
there's not a black widow film in the
works yet
um I yes I don't know how to answer that
she's few yeah I think I'm think one of
the really the I think one of the
qualities in the widow that I that I um
love and I'm interested in is that she
um you know is she's you know when faced
with this kind of she's kind of put in
the work and she's you know she I feel
like she's at a place where she's able
to you know kind of maybe do something
for herself and and and make this you
know kind of maybe even have a
relationship with somebody maybe even
open up in that way there's this kind of
greater calling this this that that's
that's pulling her and she very
selflessly chooses that and it's it's
heroic in a big way in a small way
you know she's she's really kind of in
herself which is interesting because she
also plays a character that's very I
mean she also actually does play curse
she's very kind of slippery fish for her
job um but when you get her Natasha
she's in herself which is kind of cool
um and she's in her sexy self um and
yeah a black widow movie that would be
cool you know I'm always happy to put
the cat suit back on um get in front of
all those mirrors just like Robert I'm
an actor so you know from your lips to
Marvel's big big pocketed ears there's a
lady here in the second row thank you my
question is to all of the Avengers and
other than your own characters who do
you all think had the most interesting
story arc in age of Ultron
well should we start from the middle
this time with mr. Downey and spread out
I will not understand their whose arc do
we like besides our own correct
Hawkeye's got a heck of an arc this time
yeah and also I think I can say from us
who have gone before that the the arcs
of what happens obviously Paul has a a
very interesting turn and and also with
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch I feel
like Paul and Lizzie and Aaron came out
and they exceeded expectations out of
kind of left right in the center field
and I feel like in watching the film I
was like wow that's in some ways is is
the big triumph of the film I really
liked I liked Scarlett in Ruffalo you
know you see a lot of nice intimate
moment yeah
it's my art it was the best movie
it was just nice seeing you know it was
nice seeing the the intimate moments
between you know scarlet and ruffle on
this kind of like challenged
relationship among a team of superheroes
where you'd only see romance you know
especially within the group
nailed it scarlet good luck me
y-yeah rough ah you're up scarlet uh I
thought Joss's arc was really
interesting yeah I probably agree with
with Chris I yeah I think I like to see
it was great to dive into Mark Ruffalo's
character I thinking in the whole can
just see such a sensibility in that
beast and think there's a it was quite
an emotional journey in this one zone
Hawkeye I love the um III for me it was
really the heart of the movie I found it
really moving and and he's fantastic in
it so so there you go let's go back
yellow bunny mr. Ruffalo I would also
have to say that
Hawkeye storyline I found great as an
actor who who is off and away from home
fighting imaginary evil guys and a wife
who's at home saying where the hell are
you and why aren't you here I really and
find that I'm very sympathetic to that
right no no it's your storyline so you
already know it you've ordered Emily no
I like I like them all I'm not going to
pick one out
I mean I think it's a it's a huge huge
testament to Joss to to be able to write
a movie to put all of these characters
that are all extremely interesting and
flawed and fantastic and I think it
there it's it's like a chessboard and
you think you need all these pieces for
any of them to make sense and
I'm just a very appreciative that we're
able to dive into deepen the characters
a little bit more and your purple job is
this what it's like on set well no some
of them are paying attention sometime
right back to you Olsen yeah III the
scarlet Ruffalo I through line I love
and my favorite moment is the first time
we watch a black widow talk down the
Hulk I just think that's such a
beautiful moment in the entire film I've
seen that moment twice and it's um and
that's one of my favorite parts in the
film Oh long way through the entire cast
sexist slippery slope guys let's move on
swiftly from history I can change my
density at your side a gentleman in the
year oh thank you question four for jaws
and the Avengers films are like Marvel's
Super Bowl
really and how much of a constraint is
that to you as a writer to hit certain
beats make a billion dollars and as a
follow-up how far do you think the
superhero genre still has to go well um
you know I don't I don't I don't if I
had a key on my computer that said
billion dollars I would press it I just
try to write it as well as I can I don't
really think about those things the
restrictions as I said before are
sometimes frustrating sometimes very
useful because the page is not so blank
and I'm sorry what was the second part
well you know the thing I loved about
Marvel Comics is the thing I love about
what Kevin Feige is doing with Marvel
Universe which is he approaches
approaches every movie as a completely
new idea as a movie of some particular
genre that happens to have superheroes
in it he's not interested in creating a
formula he's interested in creating a
universe so as long as he can stay alive
which is I think probably a few months
more um you know I think it has legs as
long as somebody who really cares is at
the head you know trying to create new
versions of the superhero movie and not
just fall into a pattern then it
consists in for quite a while as a lady
here thank you all of you actors are
very famous also for character driven
parts and I have just wonder if you
approach a part like an Avenger
differently if it's an action movie do
you have more fun or is it the same kind
of work it may be a little different in
an action film there may not be as many
tangible opportunities to play off of as
an actor you know some actors where the
reality is a little more grounded given
the environment you're enter the
characters you're playing off of you may
have something more to kind of pull from
and it move it like this you may be
sitting on a green screen or talking
about tennis ball but I think everyone
up here has a very healthy imagination I
think everyone up here grew up running
around in their backyard with a cape
around their neck so it's it's you know
it's a different muscle but but I think
it's a very similar approach held that
one - well played can we all agree that
Evans is on fire today Evans you're on
damn fire
Redd and Chris you were the only one
sitting around talking to a tennis ball
that we know you comfort you but it's a
little weird there's a Gemma here in the
fourth row thank you
it's a question for the mark and Ford
Ross really just kind of um considering
where Hulk ends up at the end of the
film which shouldn't be a spoiler for
anyone here do you kind of take that as
suggesting that Hulk's going to
disappear for a while or that he's going
to kind of come back in a bigger way in
future do you want to tell them no it's
you go I can't sorry it's too amazing
there's a jumper here in the second row
on the very very left thank you
hi I just really want to thank you guys
for being a constant form of inspiration
and escapism for me ever since I was 10
seven years ago but also my question is
actually aimed at Jeremy I was wondering
you you want to happy with the way that
Hawkeye was displayed in the first film
as far as it's been reported anyway but
I was wondering I know your parts been
expanded in this film but would there be
any comic book storyline or in fact any
storyline at all you'd like to adapt
with that character I don't really read
comics so I can't answer that part of it
I let writers that know what they're
doing do that and I'll try to do what I
got to do yeah and this one I was so
happy I remember we're talking about I'm
not going to talk about specifically
what happens in this movie but the ideas
of water in this movie I remember
sitting with with Downey and Joss and
Ruffalo talking about like some really
cool ideas and they were able to
implement them in this one was actually
very very very exciting and very
thankful there's a lady in the front row
thank you on the left
I thank God my arms were really aching
and I'd like to ask Paul about his
character in the film because you've
been part of the Marvel Universe since I
am
man which was the first in this little
things what's it like now being
physically on screen and not just a
voice
hot and by the way my friend really
fancied you is the vision which Lil Bit
was really odd um I know I got to move
over that one really quickly it was
lovely you know I was lovely to finally
be on set with a bunch of people that
I've been supposedly working with for 10
years but hadn't really met so that was
nice
it's a double-edged sword initially my
job was turning up at the end of the
movie with the superhero power that if
anything was still unclear I could
clarify it by just talking and then it
would take two hours and they'd give me
a big bag of cash and then I would I
would go home and I couldn't imagine
that the contract could ever be better
you know than that you know than that
but it was it was I mean as it was a
dream honestly everybody was so
welcoming there are a bunch of really
lovely happy well-paid actors yeah it's
that's a nice environment to work in you
know you got a big bag of cash bag of
cash well you know when I was doing the
The Voice it seemed like a big bag of
cash to me
box office bonuses big bag of cash
you've done a well out of this is
alright we have time for one last
question from a gentleman right at the
very very back if you keep your hand up
there certainly on the freighter I left
on the camera podium the camera podium
he's waving he's waving his hands
frantically now he's jumping up and down
he really wants ask this question right
at the background yes yes there we go
as him excuse the delay it's Tom Wester
halt
a German public radio question to Jaws
so maybe you could to clean up with some
whatever rumor or hoax past couple of
days these seen at the credits men
cleaning the windows spider-man in the
back yeah that's done real I don't know
where that started it is not in fact
part of the movie and I don't know who
came up with it we wanted to be clear
that there was no tag seen at the very
very end of the film
because after sitting through 40 minutes
of credits I'm not seeing anything we
thought people would become irate so no
I don't know where that started in the
short ones to rock down in jr. Joban
okay last one okay okay why again
did your trader pocket the shooting have
the same size as everybody else's
traders together again I read about that
so the question about the film is we
want to have a question about the film
ideally if not we're gonna bring it all
to an end that's it on that definitive
bombshell thank you so much they thank
you everybody thank you just made mine
this man Olson Jeremy Renner
you